yeah okay so so you were very depressed
in the last talk or two we've done right
yeah i was very depressed but i was
going through a lot of traumas because
living on the streets is hard because um
traumas that you've never had being
homeless
can like create uh fears
and and and
scares and traumas in your life like
having to change in front of people on
the [ __ ] street and
and like
i've always looked at people in their
face all right
and that's cause the trauma because when
you become homeless and you look at
people in their face
and if you can you feel like
you can read their expressions in their
body language
and a lot of times you feel like when
they look at you
they're directing them towards you
it
even though a lot of times it can be all
in your head i guess
and then other times not i mean it just
creates trauma i don't look at
people in their face i am
i'm i can't hear now out of my left ear
i don't know i haven't been able to hear
like so now like um
i i hear things like
like i swear to god the other day when
i'm in the women's restroom by myself
somebody kept saying my name and telling
me to get downstairs
and i was like i ran to security and i
was like
did you call me and she's like no i said
are you sure
i was like girl i could have sworn
somebody came in the room and like
yelled stephanie and hurry up and
somebody's downstairs waiting on you and
she was like no i wouldn't [ __ ] with you
like that and but it's like you know i
i'm i just can't hear out of that ear i
didn't lost the [ __ ] tooth in the
front of my mouth i got to go see a
dentist
so your drug use we never really got
into that
that causes a lot of psychosis too what
have you been using in the past
um well coming to california was the
first time i ever used
i ever left the state uh states that i
was from
and whenever i left the states i was
from i i never even
touched crystal and and
and then until i would go back to like
louisiana
uh and in coming to california was the
first time
that i actually uh started using it
outside my home state
and you know and i smoked weed all the
way up
to when i got here you know and i
thought you know great california a
great wheat city california i thought
when i got
here you know it was going to be all pot
and marijuana and
when i got here was the opposite it was
all crystal
and i and i somehow got caught up in the
wrong crowd like i always do
what does crystal meth do for you um
it's a sex thing
it's a sexual thing definitely uh
it increases your libido it makes me
horny as [ __ ] but
i like and a lot of people i guess i
guess the party and pi
could you do this kind of work on the
street without used to
when i first started crystal meth if i
take one [ __ ] hit
i would pay you not to let have me walk
out your door if it was day
day time i used to be paranoid as a day
like when i was when i would get high
and then from regular use i just
eventually now
i could smoke and like normal i could go
to work
bust my ass i could walk down the street
i can conversate with people
um no but i mean doing sex work can't be
the easiest thing to do
straight right um
i don't think i've ever done sex work
sober
so that's that's where i'm going so
crystal meth kind of opens those
knocks down those walls and you can just
do whatever you want to do right um
your inhibitions go away yeah so yeah
kind of sort of going off whatever um
but i always
i'm always safe about sex
regardless like no drug or anything
is going to come between me and safety
first
always safety first i mean because you
lift your guard there
for a second and you're going to catch
an std i mean they're rampant
you know so i always i'm always
protected you don't
it's it's it's it's never made me wake
up the next day and forget
to do something safety wise um
it helps with my traumas that's why
that's why i smoke i know i shouldn't
hide behind
i shouldn't use it as an excuse or
whatever but
i mainly do it for my traumas it's what
calms me down
something that speeds so many is used as
a speed
it actually calms me down it's like the
opposite for me
uh when i smoke weed i get paranoid
um i can't i couldn't put pull a trick
if i tried on marijuana
but when i smoked crystal it just it
calms me down
i don't know i i use it a lot less than
i used to
how many how many tricks were you doing
night
oh no i'm about the laziest hoe you know
i mean and a lot of it
to me it's a drag it's a drag it's not
what it used to be out there anymore
it's like
you get a lot of guys who want to pull
up and say 20 bucks 40 bucks
and you know what i use i'll usually
tell them look
you still got 40 bucks you still got 20
bucks because i'm sorry that's just too
much work
i mean unless you want me to give you 12
minutes for 20 bucks
sure but you better do it in 2012
minutes
otherwise i'm out or i just i usually
just turn them away
but you know we've often done things you
know um
i mean i like i like working online
usually because online the money's
better
it's it's a more trustworthy
more upscale uh clientele
they usually don't play games they
usually pay you upfront
and it's much much more money like
you're talking
opposed to 40 60 bucks
150 on a lucky day a really good day
maybe 400
on a client but online it's 250.
so you can get 250 a client like it's
and how many of those were you doing but
if a [ __ ] steals your phone
like i had another [ __ ] still my
phone again
you know it's like every time i get
friendly well
like i like i saw this guy new you know
he had never done me wrong i decided to
be friendly and hang out with him
i lifted my guard for a minute went to
buy a necklace from a vendor
turned around he stole my phone out of
my purse i had a conniption fit
i lost it on the street i was screaming
and hollering
i thought i thought i was going to die
because i couldn't afford to buy another
phone
i can't turn a trick without a phone so
it takes
it took me all the way back to square
one so your existence is day by day
so if you see me hauling outside
if that that's because most likely
somebody stole my phone and put me right
back at rock bottom at square one
do you live basically day by day
it's basically i mean i don't i have a
job i don't know what i'm gonna make
from day to day i don't know if i'm
gonna turn a trick at all
um it really depends on confidence you
gotta
it's it's your confidence like if i
don't have one
aspect of my makeup
then i mean that can ruin my whole mood
running me from getting a date i mean i
had panic attacks
like behind makeup behind my hair behind
my clothes
you know and now that i'm in a shelter i
don't as much have to worry about people
stealing that stuff for me
you know so tell me about i mean we know
you go through depression because the
other talks are
you're in that state of mind but what
about anxiety or shame
or anger oh i'm going through all that
for sure excuse me
um do you ever have good days yeah
i have good days most definitely i mean
oh god tell me i can remember a good day
um i would have in the past gone through
more bad than good but
um it's getting a lot better for me
um i'm one of my clinic's favorite
when i go over to tamara dale they love
me they cater to me to the core
they'll soak my feet for me they'll
if i ask them for clothes they'll go to
their uh
secret clothing stash and get me clothes
um and they always give me what i want
to
um do you have friends huh friends
i made one last night she was sweet
she actually came to me and told me she
wanted to be my friend i was like
i was pretty shocked because i
i don't think i make friends well i
really don't like
i i've always struggled with that
since i was a kid and i still struggle
with that
but that has more to do with your
self-perception that has to do with
my being sheltered i know it does
because
like i still am learning how to
carve like what's the word
um socialize
and and congregate with people and like
i'm still learning uh to do that
like especially in conversation it is
my is my
i am the worst because i
i'm always looking for the cut in in the
conversation like the pause whenever i
hear someone pause i always think it's
my cut in
in the conversation it's my turn to
speak but people always accuse me of
cutting them off
and you know it that's all from the like
i when i say i was sheltered grounded
five years at a time
and did every day and like it didn't
wasn't allowed to have
friends growing up friends come to my
house they were turned away by my
parents
i mean i was locked in my room all the
time i mean
i just and by the time i got out and was
able to socialize and have friends and
stuff i mean
i i've i've i've always had problems you
know i
i in a lot of times i can't really
decipher who my friends really are
especially here in the street
yeah you know and and friend is really
overly used and abused word by a lot of
people you know
um a lot of times i can't really
identify
i have problems identifying actual
friends
you know i mean i really do it's it's a
problem
um you know so
when you were a kid did you ever feel
loved in your life as a kid or is it
adult
not really no
definitely not um
no i i maybe by my
parent i thought about my parents you
know
about my sister at least but they all
disowned me and went
so i don't have any family anymore um
i didn't really have any friends ever i
i
this is my home now i had to have no
home anymore
you know um
i mean i
if you ask me right now to name five
friends i'm
i'm not sure i could actually i get
identify
any actual friends because i
i don't know one minute i think
someone's a friend and
i have to i have to double guess it and
like
i'm never sure who my friends are no
that's something i struggle with
it's sad really yeah and doing this kind
of work it's not very likely you're
gonna
make a good connection yeah you know
what the weirdest part is in this
work line of work i i
god it's so fairy tale but i kind of
thought that
i would meet a nice guy not abusive
somebody treats me kindly with respect
and
i actually it's a dream
i mean it's not real it
couldn't happen but i used to think
maybe it could
you know because that's kind of what i
want i wanted you know
yeah i just not to be alone
you know the company i like the company
aspect of it too
yeah i mean i'm so social and
i like to get out and try to make
friends and be social i love that i love
the positivity
you know i
you know i just i don't know
lots of contradictions with you yeah
it's hard on the body
it's definitely hard on the body and
i had some recent abuse yeah
i don't know i would really speak on
camera but
let's just say i stepped into a guy's
car and he
started telling me how he was in love
with me and
how i was playing with his feelings and
all these weird things he was saying and
then threatened me and
i was scared at first
you know but i uh
i'm okay i survived that one you're a
survivor for sure
totally yeah i'm sorry
i am a little tired because i did work
last night did you sleep last night
um hold on let me put it this way i have
something about
two days
i tried
um usually i i sleep every night
it's just in the last few days i haven't
really slept i've been extremely
stressed
the last two days i i
spent probably six hours
in the bathroom yesterday brushing my
hair i
stress because i was so stressed out
what do you worry about most
my appearance
my masculine features so so if you boil
that if you go another
layer deeper as i like to do what that
really is is more about
you not feeling not being loved
right is that what that is well it's not
about you don't look good enough
you know yeah you scrape away that top
layer and like
why are you worried about not being
attractive enough because it means you
won't be
i do worry about that a lot i do
you know i wish i didn't but it's just
and then we recreate our biggest fears
and your biggest fear
which probably comes i'm playing analyst
here uh
because of the child that you had you're
probably right i like to be told by
people that would do
i look good it makes you feel good
totally yeah
yeah totally but i'm i'm doing better
i'm doing better my life my life is
it's getting better and the key to
feeling loved is
loving yourself there you go
and once you do that your energy will be
different i want to say i love you'll be
much more attractive
yeah i i want to say i love myself
i i don't hate myself um
you know i've always had a problem
identifying
with my feelings a little bit too like
it's
been an issue in my life a lot um your
family probably
they will know my doctor but your family
made you feel like you're
my my doctor actually helped me
discover that when i was in her office
before i left new orleans
and i picked my doctor who
this man she i was down in new orleans i
never
picked my doctor before like we just
found each other
and if i ever went back that would be my
doctor she
she you know her and i like nine inch
nails true resin
yeah baby and she will tell me this
story about how she
was a welder too like me and she made
this one's big candle things they
haven't like it's your girl sometimes
with the candlesticks and
she didn't know how to give it to trent
resner because she made it for him
so she just went by his house and threw
it over his wall
all right and she don't know if he ever
got it or anything but after that
conversation with her it's like we
are connected she um
where was i going with this but yeah she
she
one day she asked me how i feel you know
a lot of times
you know i never really realized i'd do
it but i i do i tell people i don't know
i don't know not really sure because if
i tell the person how i feel
then after i tell them how i feel i have
to rethink it and i'm not sure it's
actually how i feel i'm not really sure
how i feel
and i wouldn't look her in the face and
thing i'm not paying attention to
but she noticed it and she
described to me after that she thought i
had a
problems identifying with my feelings
because i guess it's a sign of someone
who has that
issue so i have that issue so i i'm
never really sure how i feel do you feel
like you oppress a lot of your negative
emotions
and just put on a happy face for
everybody because you have to for work
right
you can't go you can't go out working
right now i'm not happy all the time but
yeah
i think i definitely do that yeah for
sure
and we all do it to some extent yeah for
sure
i definitely do i think i
i i put on a pretty good fake smile
um genuinely
very
happiness and true laughter
it just it has a certain look
and positivity and feel about it you
know like
i don't i yeah i don't think i'm
happy a lot like even though my life's
getting better
i'm not sure that i'm happy
yeah it's so weird
i never really thought about that but
maybe i'm not happy
but i'm not like suicidal or anything or
anything like that like i had been in
the past
um
you know maybe i should see a shrink or
something
you know um definitely
because i would like to be happy here
i would like to be happier um
because good things do happen people
want to be around you when you're happy
people can feel the negative when you're
negative and
and usually that's when they have prior
obligations
you know and i hate that
you know um
so yeah yeah thank you for uh making me
realize that
yeah i think i think a lot of people
deal with that too
yeah it's not rare it's common i think
yeah
um
yeah because i definitely want to get on
camera at some point and
and tell you about some happy moments
and it's it's i can't believe
that i i can't even think of anything
did you read the comments on your
previous videos
the what the comments um a lot of
positivity came your way a lot of people
wanted to help you
really oh yeah a lot i had no way to
reach you because you didn't have phones
i started to oh i've had phones it's
just
every time i i let some guy close to me
or yeah but the number changes weekly
oh yeah actually it does um
but you know what i i paid for all my
phones
like i will not go out and get an obama
phone so let's go back to the comments
on your videos
do you do you no i wish i had i wish i
had
i've started watching my videos and
like you don't understand i don't
like my phone voice and i nobody
when i heard that video voice i was like
oh my god it sent
fringes down my spine i was like is that
what i sound like oh my god
so um
i apologize for that and i will do
better
but you said you told me and as soon as
you release me
i will jump right on my videos and i'll
check them out because you know
you told me some people came up to you
on the street and helped you out right
yeah they were very nice they recognized
you
i had a couple come up to me and they
were like
stephanie and i'm like who's saying my
name i don't know that voice so i turn
around i'm like oh hey
they're like hey i saw your documentary
with such and such
i was like oh okay thank you i was like
did you like it and they were like yeah
yeah
and they were like oh you were so
genuine and you you really spoke to me
and
and i totally relate and stuff like that
and they were like um
can i get you any coffee or anything i'm
like oh you're sweet
and so i you know they reach out to give
me their time
i i owe it to like give them a little
bit of mine
and and it's it doesn't hurt and it's
harmless and
um you know nobody owes me anything
you know but everyone is very sweet
and kind and i appreciate um
all the comments and all the reaching
out and the sweetness and the kindness
um and
i i owe it to my fans to check out the
comments and
maybe respect yourself can i respond to
any of course
i can at first okay exciting because i
definitely would do that
i can't believe that i think it'd be
good for you too i can't believe i
didn't do it sooner
yeah the the the interviewees that have
done it
have had great experiences okay except
for a couple early on that
ended up finding stalkers and that's the
different story you know
that's why i can't give out contact info
i've had the comments are
the best way to reach anybody because i
can't give out everyone's contact in
focus
i have a serial killer in my hands well
you know i don't mind a stalker
me as long as you're not like a certain
killer stopper well that's how do you
um i'm
kind of a bit of a freak so you know
a stalker no serial killers
um i'm glad you're doing better
oh thank you your mood seems much more
upbeat so maybe some positive things did
happen in my life yeah well you got
housing and that's a huge one
yeah well may not be the but it's it's
the in between
uh transitional you know and it doesn't
have to be the taj mahal
i'm not i'm not bougie like that you
know i'm not
i grew up in a middle class neighborhood
with a golf course
course and every cookie cutter houses
and every lawn the same but
you know i that was my past
i mean tell me your thoughts on
happiness what what what do you
what would make you happy for some
people it's success and money
what would make me happy you think it is
my happiness always
alive with traveling i used to travel
my ass off at a certain age
i i traveled so much at a certain age in
point in my life
that once upon a time people used to
find it absolutely unbelievable
the things that i had done in the places
that i'd been at the age that i was
it's all kind of caught up to me now
catching up now but
i mean you name it i
just about i put my foot in every state
in the united states
and you [ __ ] name a state i probably
tell you plenty about it
and there's a few there's maybe a state
or two
or three that and that's it that i
haven't really
fully explored but i mean at the drop of
a hat and a drop of a dime if you'd say
hey
bird you want to hop right here do you
want to hitchhike over here do you want
to do this
go catch this festival i was i was
down i would drop what i was doing i
don't care if it was my employee badge
i'd drop it and i would go and i
i was always where i had my happiness
lied
you know and
i like art i love art
i i'm no expert but i know a good bit
about art
you know um you know
and some people can peg me as an artist
uh
which is amazing that um i love clowns
love clowns oh do i
yeah i used to do clown sometimes rarely
i but i've done clown before
i've done clowns what does that mean i
you've you've dressed up as a clown or
have i
right here in san francisco i have it's
been about two to three years ago but
i used to do that we just go to parking
garages and take pictures i just do
gothic clown i just knew gothic clown
yes i did
um so you're a transgender
crystal meth addicted prostitute clown
i would but you're still lovable oh
thank you
i am i'm sweet by nature yes you are
very sweet
um but uh i've i've thought about maybe
just
doing some art i find art creative
creative work to be very therapeutic
yeah yeah most definitely keeps you
right on track
do it it keeps you on track what's your
favorite art like
this ah of course that's what i do now
that's right photography yeah
ever since i was a little kid i was
always creating something
yeah never never stopped i i can i can
probably say the same about i love to
like
i love to recreate clothes
like unfortunately i don't have
all the materials i wish i had like
because there's so many things that they
don't let me bring in this building
across the street like sewing needles
uh scissors uh uh fairy nail clippers
which
trust me i have it all anyway because
yeah i mean uh however i can't like put
a sewing machine in my breasts but
you know uh you know things i wish i had
because i
i i'll go in the bathroom and i'll start
like cutting something up
and i'll go i don't have sewing needle
and thread
and you know because i i
love to make clothes and then like when
i
when i have access to material and i
have access to clothing
even clothing that's already made into
something if i see
something on it i'll tear it off i'll
cut it off
and i'll make my own [ __ ] out of it i
always got compliments
i've even had people two or three times
on the street come up to me and tell me
like when i have access to the right
materials and stuff
and i make stuff because i've got so
much stuff to make stuff with people
actually
have walked up to me on the street and
told me that i should like get paid to
pick what people
like wear from day to day or i've had
one lady tell me that
i should like design women's clothing
which i thought was like oh
you're sweet thanks but i'm blushing you
know
i mean i could be a career there for you
but
like no tvs no radios i'm nothing in
this [ __ ] place i am bored to death
and like all these half projects and
stuff and then oops
uh sometimes i make stuff and i like to
do above the knee
and like i have a few like things that i
made recently that i got cut
too short um
like the other day i i was like i needed
some money so bad
that i said [ __ ] it i wore a t-shirt and
a pair of paintings
and i walked out of the building and um
you know i got some dates
yeah i had an asian chick pull over she
was like how much
and i just got out of abusive guy's car
and i was like
i quoted her a price like way hella high
and then i just like
walked off like i didn't care and didn't
pay no money to and it was
like my equilibrium was off my balance
was out
you get picked up by women as well um
sometimes really
oh trust me i'll dike in a second
i'm such a square not me i'll die in a
second
ts girl girl oh so so they're guy you
know me
they're they're lesbian oh no no i mean
i mean i don't well
dyke is probably a um i shouldn't use
that word
that's actually not what they call that
that's
politically correct that's yeah that's
actually
more like disrespectful i'm sorry
for using that term i apologize for that
um
oh yeah you don't matter to me like a
girl a guy
a transgender or um
yeah in a second i'm pretty sexual
i mean there's um
i find myself very sexually inclined
there's not
hardly a thing sexually on a planet i
haven't
done um
at least once what's the wildest thing
you've ever done
while this thing genius
um
i don't know where do you draw your line
on wild something i don't i don't have
any
line to do
i don't care in your life
well recently i um
i've always been paranoid to like
return tricks outside closed walls
like that's a fear like getting
caught you know like um
dad doesn't get my juices flowing that
does not turn me on
and that is like a total shrinker for me
anything that could shrink on the body
will shrink
but recently i i just like i guess i've
been just getting brave or something
because like i turned one
broad daylight between two cars on a
busy street
i was like okay all right
hurry uh can you hurry how fast can you
do this i was like okay
all right whip it out well i'm just like
that's kind of flashing out for me too
because i don't usually do things like
that i'm like
very much a lady about things and very
discreet
and that's pretty trashy
whatever gets you off though
or them or them yeah
um so let's see
and it is even better to see you and
tell my fans that
i apologize for ghosting y'all and i
will
respond to all of your messages i don't
care if there's like 500
i'll respond to them all it might be
good for you cool
cool um
and you know i love you man i love you
too stephanie all right cool
and i love all y'all too i'll come visit
every time i'm up here all right and
i'll i will be well slept next time